[Music]
welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm joined by
kieran kenny who is the founder of
zealous recruitment and they are a
specialist
software sales recruiting agency and
have been going for
just over a year so uh been um a quarter
of their life
going through battling through coved an
interesting first 12 months
yeah so um look really excited to to
have you on
kieran and look where i always like to
start on this show is
how did kieran kenny into the world of
recruitment let's let's start there
um i think it's something i remember
like it was yesterday i could tell you
exactly where i was when i had the phone
call i had um
so i had spent probably three three and
a half years in the property space
really i guess outgrown where where the
potential was
i'd heard about recruitment i guess the
negative connotation that comes with
it and i had a guy ross bond from
senator
in uh wilmslow rang me i was uh
sat outside of mcdonald's at the time um
stereotypical and now
he said look have you ever really
considered recruitment and
i guess probably like a lot of people i
was like no not something that i've
looked into massively and
that looked the earning potential at the
time i was
probably 19 20 something like that
um it's like look this is this is the
next big thing
obviously it's been around for for a
while but it's still the next big thing
so yeah went went for interview there
ultimately
came away with probably the same
expectation i had beforehand
and i mean when i interviewed there
there was like it was like a big glass
office there was
people pissing about through the window
making faces the guy into
me wasn't taking it very serious walks
away from
recruitment probably with the same
impression i had beforehand i then had
a guy ash knight erector quite well
known in manchester said kieran look
you need to give us all a second chance
so he had me
four or five interviews i interviewed
with half of manchester
it got rejected i just couldn't could
not get a job
um what why
i think i've been very very successful
where i was in property i held every
company record
um i was i mean i was like 19
20 i haven't bought a house have been
very very successful and
i guess i probably had a bit of an ego
um thought i was the next big thing
and really had i achieved that much
probably not
so yeah i got rejected by four or five
companies saying kim you'd probably
set our office if you came in here
bullying behind the shop so
really really struggled so i ended up
going to investment uh property
investments i stayed within
the sector i was in and then i had a
friend of a friend
just being placed by a wreck to wreck
a good friend of his at the time a guy
called harrison scott in manchester who
then went on to my boss and he was
business partners with sean mccleary
owner of
insight recruitment in manchester he
said kyra come on
look we'll give you kind of one last
shot so i went and interviewed darren
yeah i got the job took like a massive
pay court i'd been earning a fortune
and i went and took 18 grand um there
when i've been earning
50 60 000. why did you do that i was
desperate to get in recruitment
really i'd hit the ceiling of where i
was i was desperate to get in
recruitment everyone was selling me the
dream but no one would come and let me
live the dream
so yeah those guys
found finally talk took a punt on me
went and uh
so yeah i ended up ended up working
there for as much my first job
i mean it took me probably 12 14 months
to get into recruitment for someone to
finally take a punt on me and
unfortunately those guys
finally gave me the chance i was waiting
for okay
so just just for everyone listening the
context is that so you ended up working
at insight for just over a year
then transitioned into strive sales
and and then obviously after that
started zealous right
yeah so i i did 14 months or so
and with insight obviously built built
up fairly fairly quickly had a guy in
our office obviously harrison who
was was a wreck to wreck obviously
business partner sean was doing wreck to
wreck at the time was doing the
the enterprise sales space where the
fees were
mind-blowing um obviously he was in our
office
i mean i was seeing him banging up 20 30
grand fees on the board whereas
the average guy team recruiting fee in
manchester is probably five six seven
eight thousand so saw the starry lights
went there for
i think i was only there six weeks and i
was out of the startup environment i had
a guy in the office who
an old friend of mine a story i'm sure
will come on to was pushing me saying
you know why don't we set up and i
thought well i might start up now
i might as well go and try and try and
give it a go on my own so
did 14 months within sight six weeks
with
uh strive and then yeah set up on my own
probably at the time very very out of my
depth
still still figuring it out to this day
but
yeah had quite a quick transition from
joining the industry to actually going
on my own where where did that
confidence come from then kieran because
i think a lot of people have those
conversations right
kieran i think we should we should set
up on our own let's do it
like there's a lot of talk but i think a
lot of people don't
don't take the plunge so having having
worked in the industry
for yeah 14 months where do you think
that confidence came from
so i mean i i was fairly successful
um in the site i think i did
unless someone wants to disagree with me
but i think as far as i can remember i
was the top
biller in the company in year one in the
whole company
um with with no experience on a cold
contract desk from scratch
i was like look i can i can clearly
perform and
i think that the guy who ended up
probably pushing me had just be into a
tony robbins
um big big seminar with his with his dad
and
he'd come we're like okay we need to we
need to start up and look i was all
everyone who i've ever worked with knew
i would go on my own at some point i
wasn't sure what i would do and
where i would do it but i was always
going to open my own business and
i think that was kind of the final
portion i was about that
we're not quite ready yeah probably not
it looks like the queue we can make it
work we can make it work so
he was probably the one that ended up
pushing me to
for us to go on our own um which again
i'm sure a story might have come on to
but
i think look seeing that i could deliver
results
um realistically i think that one of the
big deciding factors was being the
number one revenue generator
in um in year one i was like is there
really anyone here i can learn from
who can i look up to that was the
biggest thing and it was like well
do i go and work for someone else and
then realistically commit another two or
three years to learn it from someone
else
so do i go and try on my own was
probably the deciding factor in
the pull of trying on my own was bigger
than going to try somewhere else
that's interesting and i think i've
heard that a lot
is it was difficult position to be in
isn't it when
you feel like who
who who can i inspire to be or who can i
learn from that there will be people
around me that you can learn from but in
terms of
if you feel like there's no one that you
can look up to that can be quite
difficult can't it
my ethos has always been the same learn
from the best
learn from the worst so copy what the
best do and adapt and avoid what the
words do
and i think you can learn from everyone
doesn't matter how good someone is
whether they're the worst performer in
the office look at what's going wrong
for them and make sure you avoid that or
look at the top performer and work out
what's what's going really well for them
i think
the guy is a guy jack gleaming who was
probably the top
guy at the time in sight um i can't
remember the exact numbers he was doing
they weren't
i think i mean they weren't spectacular
i know he's gone on to do some
after i left he went on to to achieve
some great great results i think he'd
got to a stage where he'd built his desk
and one of the things i worked on was
building a great foundation i mean he
worked on the basics
of make sure your candidates in the
right place you know what you're doing
you come in with a plan every day and i
think that's something that i took a lot
from of
okay he's the top guy of course at the
time the numbers of course weren't
phenomenal
um and i know that the foundation he put
in place he went on to to do some great
stuff with
the year after i left but i think it was
about look
that's the best that we've got right now
and and take some of the things that
he's doing and then look at some of the
people that aren't working out because
yeah
well i think you have to learn from
everyone you have a sponge
and there's something you can take from
everyone no matter what numbers they're
putting on the board ultimately
yeah i agree so you started this
business on your own
so yes i was supposed to go into
business with another guy i mean he was
due to
so i left strive he was due to leave
insight where we were both working
the month after he was doing really
really well actually a friend
i'd known him kind of years friend of a
friend more than anything came to work
with his insight
um and obviously he he was due to leave
the month after me he had a like a big
big month i can't remember the numbers
but they were
yeah big commissions down for yeah big
commission check
and uh so he came we were due to set up
on the monday
first of july so about a year ago we
were going to work for my house just two
young lads so she would know each other
a while kind of indirectly and he came
on day one
and then he was like yeah i don't know
if we can do it
i was like we both left our jobs like
we're gonna have to go
we're here now and one of the things and
ultimately i know there was a lot i
don't know exactly what was said but in
the office was
you two are both at your depth you're
both failed there's no way it'll work
like what are you both doing
and obviously i it got in his head
ultimately he was like look i don't know
if we can do it and
i was like look times are only going to
get harder than this if we don't
work out in three six months if day one
when it should be exciting if that's
where you're ready to
kind of walk away then ultimately it's
not probably not for you so
a shame really she was a good a good
friend at the time can't say we still
speak now but
that's fair he was he was he was the one
who pushed me to go which i'm
forever grateful for he was going to end
up pushing me to go and
well i mean that's one of the biggest
things i would say and maybe something
we'll touch on later for
for tips is if you are thinking about
setting up
in hindsight i would have done
everything to to keep hold of him
um i think one of the biggest why why
it's so tough mentally sitting on your
own with the pressure
i mean recruitment's an industry known
for rejection anyway
to sit all day on your own i mean you
have your best successes no one to
celebrate with you have your worst days
known to pick you up
you're trying to make strategic
decisions in a business that in a
situation you've never been in before
having that person to bounce ideas off
is invaluable in my opinion
and again probably one of the biggest
things i would recommend if anyone's
going
is is look at facts yeah
how how how did you like how did you
feel then
like like at those sort of first that
first month or so so you're like well
i'm here now i'm gonna have to do it i'm
doing it on my own like how how what was
what like how did you feel if anything i
guess what some of that fire came from i
was like
who do these guys in the previous office
think they are talking around how we're
definitely gonna fail
i was like i'm always one of those guys
you tell me i'll fail or succeed 10
times over
i've never i've never unfortunate i've
never failed anything
i've never failed and i think that comes
down to mindset i was like
but then i'm here now i'm gonna do
everything i can
humanly possible to make this business
succeed and i'll succeed 10 times over
more than any of you my previous company
have done
and that was the biggest driver for me
because it's that's a that's a dark
place to be you
you're supposed to be wrong yeah you you
set up with someone
you're ready to go sure i mean we were
both like 22 year old lads
should have been the most exciting time
of our life and it turned out being like
oh right okay i'm on my own list so by
then i was
too deep i was um i was in too deep i
thought i can't turn around
let's go so off off i went with it with
a phone
a linkedin account and started what yeah
what was the plan so what was it what
was the plan then says
we'll see intros it says specialist
software sales i'm assuming
sort of getting that um obviously that
perspective uh strive
sort of led you think well actually
there's a good market here potentially
but what was what was the plan then what
was the i don't know did you have a plan
like what
what what what was that what was i i
guess
the plan was so the guy i was working
with was doing
software easy four five six grand deals
the plumbers i look i will try and open
the software sales space
and he will continue doing technical
he'll keep us alive
while i build on some of these bigger
relationships
that was the plan for for him to keep us
alive
the the the plan then so i was
recruiting in amsterdam at the time
because when i joined strive and said
where what country do you want to
recruit
obviously young lad of amsterdam that'd
be pretty cool to do so
um they had a an employment contract
they met i couldn't really do business
in amsterdam so we
i looked at doing business in the uk now
the reason being and
for invoice factoring and for anyone who
doesn't know that is effectively
you can sell your invoice so you have an
invoice say
10 grand you can sell it to a factoring
business for nine they'll pay you
upfront and they take the ten grand and
make a thousand pounds on it
so i thought well i'll do the uk that'll
be how i can get easy money in because
they'll pay me in front of my invoices
when i make the placement and then
when it gets paid also i have to give it
to them
so started operating in the uk i thought
that would be the easiest way to get
cash in the bank quick that
didn't really work out the uk was very
very competitive so kind of a month
thing i'm sat there i'm thinking right
plan a plan b has gone out the window
so i did a bit of a survey of look with
the
hiring manager i work with where do you
struggle to find people
and time and time again they said
germany so i thought right okay
uk probably not working out for me
amsterdam i can't turn to i haven't got
the backup plan of someone doing
technical recruitment i'll go in germany
all in commit six months
see see where i go so i kind of give
myself i had enough money to stay alive
for six months
if it didn't work out then i had to i
guess go and get go and get another job
so yeah i went through a couple of plans
settled on germany and
never how did you plan to how did you
plan to crack germany then what was the
oh so you had to get clients so what was
it just straight up
just cold calling businesses in germany
yeah i mean
the biggest thing for me is that the
cold call is not dead i love bashing the
phone
first i do in the morning i come in i
hit the phone so i just hit the phone
and start dialing
judy's staff next you need any staff
next it was it was a pretty like
basic plan at the time um it's not our
bd now but
it's just find managers find people
hit the phone ask if they want any staff
if they don't great move on
it was like door-to-door selling on the
phone and and i picked luckily i picked
up a couple of clients
um from that that gave me enough to do
one or two placements and take it how
long did it take to do your first deal
so i did my first deal in october
obviously i set up in july july i just
dust around
in a couple of different countries so
really i started in august did the first
placement in
october which is a lot quicker than i
expected in all honesty
what what helps the lights still though
right
that doubts could have been creeping in
right because what august or october
couple of months there where you made
zero so
what when when when you blanked
essentially when you wasn't putting any
money on the board
it was just you what what what
made you push through that i think
a the realization though that the market
we operate in i mean you've got
six seven stage interviews so it's never
going to happen overnight the companies
we're working with the multi
multinationals some of the hottest
companies on the planet
it's not going to happen overnight i
knew the market i was operating in
and that's why plan a was to have
someone topping us up with easy deals in
the
software development space well what the
cycle is
like not as long basically yeah where
you can you can get a job on a monday
and fill it
in two weeks that would never happen i
mean it's realistically
job to fillings minimum four to eight
weeks in in the space i'm operating now
so i think the the expectation that i
wouldn't do a deal for a couple of
months was the biggest thing and
i think that's realistic and that comes
back to for when a lot of people get
into recruitment
have realistic expectations it's not
always going to happen overnight and i
think that's
been my my kind of ethos in life is
anything worth having is not going to
come easy
and knowing that it could take me some
time to get the results is what kept me
going
um okay that that's interesting how did
it feel to do your first deal then
i i i well i guess the biggest thing is
yeah it felt great but that's another
point that
you're on your own you've got no one to
celebrate with i've always been an
office guy
um anyone will tell you i've always been
an office guy and to do that deal i was
like
yes all right no really
no i've experienced that it's a weird
feeling isn't it so
well i mean it was a huge huge relief
huge huge relief because it meant i
could stay alive for a couple of months
and that was the biggest plan for me in
the first 12 months
stay alive still exist in 12 months time
so that that first one was like right i
can do it because i had never made a
placement this market before
when i was at strive i was there six
weeks i signed quite a few good clients
but
never enough time to do a deal i'd only
i was a contract biller i'd
only ever done one perm one perm
placement so it was like
right great i've done it i think the
biggest thing was prove it to myself i
could do it because
it's something i've just i've never
placed in this market and only ever done
one
one perm placement before so yeah it was
uh
it was a nice feeling what what did you
have any sort of what was your like
personal network like because i think
that's
that's what's really helped me i really
relate with that in terms of
yeah used to having a team of people to
celebrate with but
for me i've had to share those wins with
my girlfriend my friends
family sometimes and and that's given me
a bit of that but it's definitely not
the same but
like was it just kieran kenny's smashing
out in his bedroom like
what yeah yeah what was your support
network like
so i've got obviously a couple of couple
of people i um
i used to work with i still speak to on
like a daily a daily basis
and yeah look i mean at the time was
single um chasing someone else's
girlfriend um
someone else's girlfriend we know no
real financial backing to be doing so
um but yeah it was i mean i've always
been
like a family guy very very close to my
parents my dad's an enterprise sales guy
the same
as what i recruit for oh really so
yeah interestingly um so look i think i
had a couple of good friends but i'm
one of those guys that i have a lot of
associates not many friends
because i've always been a work guy my
career my life comes
over socializing where's that where's
that come from
i've always been very very driven i mean
when i was like
eight nine i had like a paper round
where i'd give up a saturday and
so i mean i started my career doing a
paper round i'd get up at
seven on a saturday and sunday to earn
three pound fifty on a saturday three
pound fifty on a sunday
so i'd give all my lines up for seven
pounds on the weekend
i've just always been at work and a
naturally motivated guy
um so it's just something that i think
has always been
drilled and instilled into me the
work ethic and work is everything so
yeah going back to the quest about
personal network not huge which i had a
couple of people
celebrated with but i think it was like
that was like relief
move move on and keep going yeah because
that's hard that right i'll respect that
that's fair um so obviously
great feeling obviously big confidence
booster as well as you said like just
real
you knew in your head that you could do
it but sort of getting that there's just
it's that realization yeah i definitely
can do this made a placement and
it's now let let's push forward so i
guess
what what did you learn through that
that maybe you sort of change your plan
or just change your approach did you
then sort of try and do more of the
things that work to get to that point
what what sort of slight changes did you
make to to push on
i think probably one of the biggest
understandings is
the difference between the perm and
contract market because contract
is very much skilled can you come in and
deliver a project you're not a long-term
part of our business
it's a short a short-term fix and a
client will pay
for a skill set whereas i think i
probably realized the first candidate i
placed
i on paper was questioning i didn't
think he was the strongest candidate
but the cultural fit was right the
drive of the candidate was right i think
one of the biggest learning points was
what someone looks for in a perm
employee to a contract employees very
very different different yeah that's one
of the things i learned from my first
placement my first couple of placements
is
the difference between that permanent
contract balance was probably one of the
biggest
learning curves i had to build this yeah
that's fair that's interesting
what about then the business development
angle like
was it just carrying on just smashing
the phones or did you change your
approach there because i think
that that's the part that a lot of
people when they make the plunge the
most worried about right
is is winning business winning new
clients obviously you just
smashed it out got on the phone but did
you then sort of change tax in terms of
made a place into this client i need to
be working with more businesses like
this or
what did you change anything or learn
anything obviously i was going to do
enterprise sales um in germany
so it was any any software i think one
of the things though
historically and something that worked
very well is just specking out cvs
get a great cv send it to 100 managers
and
somewhat someone is if it's a
proposition a proper good cv then
someone will probably buy
i think one of the things that probably
changed litter was i went
only into cyber security then so i was
yes i went enterprise so only enterprise
only software sales not only cyber
security so become a real real
expert why i think if you haven't got
that usp because i mean i was banging
the phone at first speaking to loads of
people and i had no real usp i had no
strength it was like there's loads of
people doing what you're doing kieran
you've got no track record
no strength why would you work with you
and
look i always think of myself as a good
guy on the phone i'd back myself against
most people
but without a real usp it's very
it's very difficult to leverage what
you've got so i think i really drilled
down to right okay
i've made a placement security i'm gonna
focus on that market
so that then um i started i
obviously went back from bashing the
phone to sending out some cvs and
that worked again for me i had a big
probably my biggest client today a
massive multinational business probably
one of the best security vendors of the
21st century
i had the internet recruiter call me at
the time i didn't know if it was a
candidate or
if it was a client or who it wasn't
they said it hi i'm x from y company
um i was like hello so i was a bit like
stumped and and she was like
you've been sent it was a is a head of
internal recruit for jury should
cue you said i might just that many cvs
i'm actually a bit sick of it she's like
it's easier just to work with you
so so
i had success in the early stages from
just a
cold phone bashing and b sending out cvs
and for anyone
looking to improve at business
development you have to have a range of
you can't go to market one strategy you
need to be multiple
then i had a bit of a light bulb moment
i think i can't remember when it was
november december
when you had jamie francis on the
podcast which for anyone who hasn't
listened to is
far and above the best episode that has
ever uh jeremy fraser sorry
jamie fraser james frazier sorry yeah
yeah i hope he doesn't listen to that
but
no that's okay but far and above the
best episode that
has ever been and one of the things
really struck me because i had never
worked with a top top billy before was
he said look when i business develop i
call with purpose i know what i've done
i know what i can achieve i know why the
companies and i think rather than
just cold calling i started to call with
a much more of a purpose
what if i've done what's the use case
how can i help you and why should you
work with me
and i think around december time really
started to change and that's when i saw
a lot better results i was calling with
a real purpose i wasn't just calling
hi i'm kieran have you got any jobs
there's millions of people doing that
how did you change it
i think i looked at where i've had
success what use cases did i have
um cyber security which is which helps
yes i i looked at my real speciality
and called with a and knowing
that if they answered the phone i can
genuinely help them and i have a real
strong usp a real strong talent pool
that i've built up a real strong
expertise where
not only am i helping you find staff i
can advise you on the market what should
you be paying where should you be
looking who are your competition
and i think listening to that podcast
gave me a real different perspective on
the business development because it give
me a real
this is who i am this is why you should
work me it meant i was calling with a
complete
different purpose i wasn't calling
asking someone to work with me anymore
i was calling someone telling them why
they should work with me and that was a
real
and it's really weird that because it
when you really believe that it comes
across on the phone doesn't it
and yeah 100 100 percent it doesn't
matter
where you are what you're selling if you
don't believe in your product you will
never get anywhere
yeah i've always believed when i was in
property i believed i worked for the
best estate agency in the country i just
believed that
when i was selling media i just believed
we had the best products and
if you believe in the product but then i
went back to start my own
business like do what i really believe
in what i've got now and that's why i
had to find that usp so i had something
that i truly believed in
and i had zero doubt with no i love that
sort of journey you went on there and
that's really interesting
how did you go about how did you go
about
sort of really learning about your usp
in terms of so you place this guy
or person sorry and then like what like
how did you go about learning about this
market was it just
to as many candidates as possible get
really curious do your research because
it's something that
people are always interested in how can
i open up new markets blah blah blah so
like when you recognize oh i need a usp
this is sort of where i'm going to go
down like how did you go about really
learning that market that clearly helps
with the business development and those
things what was the sort of plan there
i mean the the easiest way to put it was
i didn't have a [ __ ] clue
exactly and and and that's how
obviously i've got a new guys recently
started me i've said look
you need to ask questions get on the
phone you need
a piece of knowledge from every call
take a bit of information from every
call use it on the next one
then get another piece of knowledge
start talking around and build yourself
almost like a dictionary so i've
i've built like an office dictionary
with all the different phrases because
you have three or four phrases
you sound ten times more credible the
candidate isn't testing you
if you're recruiting sales people in
cyber security they're not going to test
you
what do you know about cyber security if
you're recruiting net developers they
don't want to know what you know about
net but if you've got three or four
phrases that you can build up and you
can build up your own little dictionary
or your own little knowledge pool
you can soon start to piece it together
and it's say for example you're building
a jigsaw puzzle
you get all the edge bits because
they're the easiest bits
then you start to fill the middle in and
you start to build
and it's the center is the last bit you
often build
and you need to work from the high level
knowledge okay this is what i know
this is what i can find out and then
start speaking to candidates but it's
not just
knowledge about the products that they
are working on the product they're
selling on the platform
it's knowledge about that market what
what have you
heard what piece of news have you heard
that you can share
and that's one of the biggest things is
ask ask
the candidates what's happening in the
market what's the hottest thing right
now
in your world and start to use that
knowledge google it research it
and really drill down but also it comes
to candidates
find two or three bits of knowledge use
that in your calls
get a bit more knowledge and write down
anything that you think could be key
write it down yeah i really like that
awesome point that'll pop up in a
conversation you'll be like
i've got something written down about
that and it just gives you a lot more
credibility i think
yeah no i really i think that's really
smart office dictionary
your market dictionary i love that
that's that's a great
piece of advice and i think where some
people sort of stump themselves on that
is sometimes you
i think recruiters when i work with them
and things when i'm talking about
building their brand and all that is
they sometimes
feel like they have to be as competent
as the people that they place but you're
never going to be as competent as they
are right which is what you're talking
about
but what what what you do need to know
is what's going on in the market
talking about like making sure that you
understand their language
and yeah like i really like how you put
that's really interesting
like when i when i was obviously
recruiting within it
i i set up an event like a data
analytics event
in manchester i was like look i i want
to get involved in this market i want to
have a passion about it
i want to see incredible i set up set up
the event with no real knowledge but it
meant that
because it was my event i could ask
questions that maybe i couldn't have
done before
i could find that knowledge that people
wouldn't have given me and you
you've got to give 110 into your market
you've got to do the research i mean
look i don't believe in all these
recruiters now who are going out and
trying to code and all that i think
that's [ __ ] personally
i'm not into going to that level because
really realistic are you ever going to
need to code how is that helping you i
i think your time could be better spent
just researching
and i think time could be better spent
just building knowledge because
yeah it's great being able to code do i
think it's worth the time personally no
um but having things like an event that
gives you
you credibility i know that there's a
guy in manchester guy called toby
willman who's now
with infinity works with mortimer spinx
he had this devops event in manchester
and i remember going to i thinking like
wow he's got
100 developers coming to see him once a
month
not about work and it was like that
again another light bulb moment like
i need to this i need to be doing this
in my market
and it's about being able to give back
because the coding in that obviously is
great but it's not giving anything back
the events you're giving back to people
you're building credibility you're being
able to talk to them
outside of work and i think researching
your market and knowing your market
inside now is massively massively
important and i'm always a believer
you you you aren't successful through
look you choose to be successful
yeah you choose to be a failure and i
think
if you go above and beyond you can
choose to be successful it's my
philosophy so i had some some really
good learnings on
working out what your value proposition
is usp
business development and all those
things so what about
so i'm assuming from that point onwards
yeah start to have more success
but what about the actual german market
then like how difficult was that to get
in like did you because i think i saw a
couple of posts about going over there
what what did you have to learn on that
front in terms of how they operate the
german culture what it's like to work
for a german business
how did you uh because look i think
again some people
i never i always work to market in the
uk
and i think again a lot of people can
assume that
people in germany aren't going to want
to speak to to kieran and
wherever you are will's lie yeah yeah
i mean like because that's something
that you could also get in your head and
have that self-talk right
like how how was that journey i think
that's
again a big big learning curve because
obviously i
was recruiting in amsterdam where i mean
you speak perfect english in amsterdam
like
you could be speaking to your mate down
the pub yeah
moving into germany one of the things
you'll find is the germans
aren't a huge fan of english headhunters
um they don't want to speech and that's
that's one of the things where it comes
back to you choose to be successful or
not
because in germany they don't really
want to speak to you um
it's i guess a lot similar to the uk but
i had to adapt and work out what made
these guys tick
um i went oh i mean i go to germany once
a month
i go and meet these guys i understand
the different culture and
you've just got to speak to a lot of
people work out i mean at first i was
trying to have like banter with them on
the phone
and i realized like they haven't got a
clue what i'm saying like
bunting well i'd be laughing like and
you'd just be met with like
dead silence because so you have to
work out and look there's loads of
businesses now recruiting businesses
operating in germany because
the culture the culture is something
that you learn the language barrier is
not something that's
massive i mean whenever anyone says to
be [ __ ] there must be a huge language
barrier
there's not there's just not um
so realistically as long as you it's
like everything at the end of the day
if i go from being estate agents who i
was recruiting database developers
that's the same cultural difference i've
got to learn a lot of them are introvert
they're not like me
it's exactly the same as learning about
if you're recruiting
engineers learn about their call just
because i'm recruiting in germany it's
no different to
having to learn the culture of your
candidates in the uk personally
yeah and how how have you dealt with i
don't know have you have you been back
back with well can we want to work with
people that
sort of operate in germany i don't know
have you ever sort of had to back that
back or objection handle
that you're based in the uk somewhere up
north
rather than i don't know have you ever
had to sort of back that up
yeah i mean that's definitely something
that that comes with
with the territory um but i think it's
it's quite well known in the market that
the german head hunters
aren't great they often have
german-based companies the uk
headquarters have a much
more pristine probably isn't the
prestige is probably the right word
reputation because we're aggressive with
business development more we have better
companies
yeah we're probably quite annoyed and we
are probably quite aggressive
i mean we i get that feedback about a
lot of
headphones as i i get that feedback
myself personally but
the uk head hunter is often a lot more
advanced than the german ones in in my
experience and look i don't want to just
make
a sweeping statement but that's right
i've been
i've been given the feedback a lot of
the english headquarters have
better opportunities so they're
reluctant to speak to us but
often the uk heads have much better
companies they are working with
what would you say is the main
difference how do you just describe the
difference between head hunter and
recruitment consultant
that's that was a question i asked ask
myself a lot
i think to be honest for me personally
i'm probably a recruiter not a head
for me a head hunter is probably someone
who works on a retained basis and has a
list of candidates a company wants
i'm probably a recruiter which is
headphones has used more
in europe okay the word headset is used
more
yeah if you actually look at the
definition of hedgehog to it as i say
it's probably somebody works on a
retained basis and works in very very
niche roles
that's probably probably not me but it's
just the terminology in germany is often
head hunter that's fair enough
so what went on i guess i guess so
december had a bit of realization
really felt like you was then doing
business development with a purpose that
massively helped let's talk about um
the last couple of months then what
what's what's i mean
so i'm assuming then you felt you would
have felt like going into
obviously this year 2020 is my year
um built obviously yeah i had a few
realizations building a bit of momentum
like what went on where was you before
coronavirus hit
like was you in a good spot was you
feeling good about things
so it was on top of the world
and then it was i guess slightly
frustrating because i was speaking to a
lot of
friends um in the uk like here in the
markets ground to halt grounds to hull
i see jeremy dealt with things pretty
well so i was like business as usual for
me lads cheers for coming
and uh all of a sudden it was like came
to a
because the uk gradually came to halt
yeah because germany
didn't really slow down and then all of
a sudden stopped i mean in march i think
i had
i lost 80 000 euros of business really
um
unless you how how did you do that
mentally mate because
it's you it's your business like small
business
what how how did you deal with that how
did you tell that on the chin
it's very very difficult and it's not
like i'm 30 40 being there
and obviously i've never really failed
before um
i mean i was being 20 23 as i have to
think that 23 as i am
never really failed before it's hard
it's definitely hard to take because
it's not something i've ever dealt with
that level of
i wouldn't call it failure or even
rejection but that level of mental
toughness i think you just got to look
and you got to look at the positives one
of the
the biggest things that i always look at
and i always say to any new starter is
at the end of daily make a list of your
wins at the end of the week
look back what have you won throughout
the week
you've got to look at the much smaller
wins what pipeline have you got what can
you generate
and i just had to look at right well
okay the revenue is going to drop off
what what can i do now to still
put me in a strong position when all
this comes to an end and i think look
any setback if you let any setback
really hit you hard
then you're always going to be
taking a step back i think you just got
to power through of course it's a very
very bitter pill to swallow and
going through that in year one of
businesses it might have been in 2008
again
but ultimately you've got to look at the
positives right what can i do now over
the next two or three months
what are the smaller tasks where can i
build relationships and the big thing i
worked on was
everyone in manchester i mean i
personally found it frightening how
tight
clearly a lot of recruitment companies
run on manchester in terms of cash flow
and what money they've got in the bank
because all of a sudden 95
in the manchester recruitment market or
the recruiting market in whole seemed to
be on furlough
and i was like right great these
managers aren't getting battered by
calls
gives me a chance now to business
develop with
five percent competition instead of 100
and i think you have to look at in in
the face of any
challenge you have to look at the
positives of what can you take out of
this and
i i very much thought right okay i've
lost revenue pac-man's gonna drop i'm
gonna struggle for a couple of months
what can i do to ensure and i just had
to keep the positive mindset of what can
i do now over the next couple of months
to make sure i'm still in a strong
position what did you end up focusing on
then
very much speaking and speaking to
clients how can
how can i help where does the growth
come from
what the challenge is going to be is
there may be a position where i can help
you in supporting you sharing market
information
i'm really just taking the chance to
speak to clients i'm not about work
they're taking the chat speed say look i
know the difficulties you're going to go
through i know the challenges you're
going to go through
what can i do to make your life easier
which as a recruiter realistically not a
lot
but going in with the right mindset and
having the right reason for the call
is a lot different than hi i'm kieran
this is how i work with this way should
work me it's a completely different call
in it
it gave me the chance to have some
conversations i probably wouldn't have
been able to have
and how how do you think that might how
do you think that's going to help you
moving like i don't know what's
happening
so far i've got a lot of people um
now that haven't been getting battered
with calls so when they do next hire
i know they will use me because i've
been speaking with them throughout
lockdown where everyone else has been on
furlough
so i've been able to build some
relationships because i've been able to
have time that i wouldn't often have had
so
the calls i have had have meant i've got
a lot of pipeline
i mean i've got a hell of a lot of
pipeline come come august end of august
the market will be frighteningly busy
for me and that's
i guess kind of thanks to coronavirus
because it's giving me the chance to
have those conversations
and business develop without much real
competition
yeah so what
one of the things that um i jotted down
before we spoke
obviously you shared like a sort of year
in business article
which i thought was really interesting
just giving your sort of tips on
anyone that's considering the plunge
what the first bullet point you put
is is about building a good foundation
so i guess
yeah obviously been in business for a
year and this has come up a lot because
it's not the typical things that
you probably thought about when you was
day one with your mate right building a
good foundation or that
right so why why why was that
sort of point one and why is that really
important and what's been your learning
on that because i think that's really
useful for people
i think you need to have a good
foundation because
you want even if it's software you want
a support network around you you don't
want everything sat on your shoulders
get a proper crm system so when you have
jobs you can find the right canvas you
can track the nose
get a proper phone system don't just
work off your mobile where you haven't
got numbers saved or your mobile bill
might be through the roof get a proper
accountant
i've never done accounts an accountant
isn't hugely expensive
but will save i mean they're worth their
weight in gold because
ultimately they will advise you where
you can save money or what you can spend
or
how to track things get a proper
like league i had a legal advisor
whenever i had a problem about terms i
mean i had never signed a set of terms
before
so when people were saying i can't sign
your terms you need to sign mine i was
like
can i sign this and all questions that
you will never have had before well
you may have done if you've been in
recruitment or a senior position in
business before but i hadn't is
surround yourself with people you can
turn to all the time
because i didn't have the answers to 70
80 percent of things
and i needed the answers so surround
yourself with good software that will
support you make your life easy it's
stressful enough
without having to scramble around on an
excel sheet trying to find a candidate
you spoke to
three months ago so take take as much
weight off your shoulders as you can do
yeah and i think
what's really interesting about that
that's come up a lot is
yeah you're having the mindset of like i
should have these things now rather than
wait until i've got to a certain
point that warrants me getting the crm
or whatever
and time and time again when i've spoken
to business owners that
have successfully scaled they're
thinking
two three four years ahead like i need
this now because i know in two years
time i'm going to be here and that
that's i need to have that
um also on that point you put yourself
around
surround yourself with with mentors
yeah i think i think that's big i mean i
i ended up meeting another guy who's in
my
office block and also does recruitment
helped me kind of
massively um he helped me when i was
hiring
help with interview tips helped me with
what to expect
helped me with what these are some of
the problems i'm having with like
software
what to expect how to put training in
place how to scale the business
a guy who helped me massively and i've
ended up being kind of like a small
recruitment network we set up ourselves
just me and a couple of other guys that
where we can bounce ideas off because
when you're having a tough life even now
we'll talk about
if we've got a small win we might share
it between each other
and having that network of people to ask
when things are not necessarily going
wrong but aren't going right i think
just
just for reassurance as well because i
think if you have a strategy you have to
stick to it for a fair amount of time
you can't just change the goal post
immediately and i think that's massively
important how people you can ask
do you think i'm doing the right thing
do you think i should change it because
especially being a kind of a one-man
business owner
naturally if something doesn't work
immediately i'm going to question is
that the right thing
and i think we know to ask and that's
why i'd say go into business as well
with someone else being able to bounce
ideas off but
having mentors around you who've done it
being there before
people to ask is absolutely invaluable
and that did that just happen quite
organically yeah happened
met him in the office at a macmillan
cake morning or something like that
ended ended up uh sharing a muffin with
him and we're not showing one muffin
obviously but
uh and the end ended up kind of taking
it from there and really kind of
i guess building like a friendship from
there and ended up
yeah to where it kind of is today so
as you come to the end of this kieran
just something that's coming up for me
that
be interesting to get your thoughts on
is how have you
how have you because i think i'd like to
think i'm just assuming here that
you may have gone through this but as
you said 23 years old
on your own recruitment business a lot
of people have
self-doubt and attached their age to not
having enough experience
am i good enough to be doing this have i
got enough experience
have you had to deal with that i don't
know because i think a lot of people
again
your age may think now i'll wait
so like i don't know have you had to
deal with those thoughts or had to
overcome that a bit what do you think
about that
i guess not the the black and white
answer is no i've always
always believed in myself and i've
always had that work ethic i mean i see
recruitment
a lot different to a lot of other people
everyone these days they want working
from home they want flexible work and
office bean bags and all that [ __ ]
that's not how i run my business i mean
i
started in a business ph media group
in manchester is known as like the the
ruthless outbound call
like call center and i wanted
my business to have that same work ethic
where you
you don't doubt yourself and i've always
said and
look obviously when i change plans at
the start of the business is
is not exactly like a plan i don't ever
have a plan b
because if you have a plan b you have an
ounce of doubt that plan a will fail
and my business is set up now where
we are relentless we work hard and
success is the only option
i think if you have any self-doubt
probably an unpopular opinion walk away
if you don't back
yourself 100 walk away because for me in
my head there is
no option to fail and yeah of course
being young
there's things that come into your mind
but doubt or think about failure
absolutely not and that's what i want to
give the platform to all of
my team now you come in work and success
is the only option
and that's why i say said earlier is
success is an option and a choice
success doesn't happen success is a
choice and for me
was i ever going to to fail law did i
have that
doubt the black and white answer is no
what what just out of interest what
would you deem
as success that's a very very good point
because
i mentioned it in the recent article of
mine success
i spent a long time thinking success was
a place or success was a feeling
success is success is a process of
achieving things
success is a journey and i mean our
tagline here is the the relentless
pursuit of success
because upset you for me you don't
succeed
you are successful success
i saw a quote on success is never owned
success is rented and the rent is due
every single day
and it's something that i live by
success is having wins
what have you achieved are you in a
stronger position now than you were
yesterday
are you in a better position now than
you were last week are you in a better
position than you were last month
and i think that is something that's
massively important i think
success you get from hard work
hard work and commitment to the cause
and i mean
three of the things that we live and die
by is
commitment personal drive
and execution and they all amount to
success
are you committed to the cause and will
you do whatever it takes
do you have the personal drive to be
successful because this business
isn't going to be successful if i've got
one person in here who doesn't have that
personal drive
and execution is something we live and
die by
is that the best you could have done
that okay so you've just sent me a cv
is that the best you could have
qualified it you've just got to make me
a coffee is that the best you could have
you've just made a call is that the best
you could have done
and if you have that commitment to
improve that personal drive to achieve
success personally but you look at
execution of
everything everything you do in a day
then you will follow the journey of
success and that's something that we
massively believe i mean when we have
quotes around the office and it's a big
big thing that
what is success success isn't a place
or an achievement success is a journey
that you stay on
you can fall off success from day to day
but if you have all the right
minor uh things that add up to success
then you can stay on that journey
yes it's an it's an important insight
isn't it that it's not a place
i think i think look i i i had it for a
long time where
i used to wake up in the morning like
i've not succeeded
and i it hit me probably nine months ago
you don't succeed look at look at the
top footballs ronaldo messi
they haven't succeeded they are
successful because every day they want
to improve
and that's massive you have to want to
improve every day that's for me
personally why i disagree with a lot of
things in the recruitment industry where
it's all about flexible working it's all
about
having fun in the office you go to work
to be successful that's my output
or my my vision of it and this whole
working
home culture it doesn't sit with me
because i want someone in the office
every day improving
i'm not about flats or working if you
don't want to give me
eight till six every day this is not the
right business for you
so we we have a real mindset of
we will do whatever it takes to achieve
our goals and that's the way the
ultimate business has worked so i think
that's one of the things when coming
back to the question did you ever have
any
doubt you would succeed the black and
white answer is no
because if you have any doubt i don't
think you will be successful
so before we finish then how are you
feeling what what sort of on your mind
going into the year two then obviously
still
riding this coronavirus confident that
thing is going to pick up for you
what how are you feeling about sort of
having looking at
thinking about what you've learned in
these things how are you feeling about
going into year two
absolutely loads loads to look forward
to and
just just obviously kind of brought on a
guy nat
recently banged in a deal in his first
month
um couldn't couldn't have asked for for
any more
um obviously going to grow the team just
moved out of germany into the uk
expanding the current clients we were
bringing on some phenomenal clients now
look if i look at my client list in
comparison to business
i don't think there's probably anyone in
my position or a similar position now
that has a client list like i do
and the ability to expand those clients
the ability to
really work and deliver over the next
year
i i see phenomenal things within the
business and we're
we're just getting started now there's
this huge things coming and
look i look forward to to bring you on
more like-minded people
because every hire for us is a step
closer to having that culture in place
so i'm looking forward to adding more
like-minded people source over the next
12 months
i love that so final words then so if
you could uh
communicate to every single recruiter
out there they'd listen to advice they'd
take it on and implement it
what would uh kieran kenny say to uh the
recruitment world
i think if you want to be the best you
have to commit you have to have huge
goals
never settle for second best for me
recruitment is an all-or-nothing
industry
and if you can't give it 110 it's not
for you if you can
it's by far the most rewarding job
you can take i love that karen it's been
a pleasure
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
for having me